حتى الآن ما كانت القواعد حتى الآن
كانت القواعد في وكالة ناسا ، حسنًا ، لذلك تبنت جميع شركات
تصنيع السيارات NAFTA NAFTA كانت
اتفاقية موقعة بين الولايات
المتحدة والمكسيك وكندا وبعد أن
حددت القاعدة لجميع صانعي السيارات ،
حسنًا الآن إذا كان هناك أي تغيير في  نافتا
وقد يكون تغييرًا في الوقت الحالي
لا نعرفه إذا كان هناك تغيير قريبًا
بعد أن نتكيف مع التغيير
إلى نافتا جيدًا ، من الواضح أننا نفترض أنه
ستكون هناك بعض التغييرات لأن
الرئيس المنتخب قال  هناك
شيئان واضحان جدًا بالنسبة لنا هما أمريكا
أولاً والوظائف في الولايات المتحدة ، حسنًا
، من الواضح جدًا أنك تقول حسنًا أنك تريد
البيع في الولايات المتحدة ،
سيتعين عليك إنتاج المزيد في الولايات
المتحدة والاستثمار أكثر في الولايات
المتحدة  من الواضح جدًا ، مع العلم
أنك بدأت بالفعل في تغيير خططك
للمستقبل مع العلم أنه
بدون أدنى شك ، أعتقد أن أي
مصنعي سيارات لم يبدأوا في
مراجعة خطته لأننا
ننتقل من موقع  في المكان الذي كان لديك فيه النفتا
إلى وضع جديد لا نعرفه ولكن
أين يقول الرئيس المنتخب للولايات
المتحدة بوضوح الوظائف الأولى لأمريكا
في الولايات المتحدة وترى
أن معظم صانعي السيارات
لم يستمعوا فقط إلى فهمهم ولكن
أدمجت هذه الرسالة في القرار
الذي رأيته في عدد قرارات
الاستثمار التي تم اتخاذها بالفعل
في الولايات المتحدة ، لذا فإن الرسالة
واضحة متى ستصدر
إعلانك وأنت تعلم أن السؤال كان ،
نعم ، متى ستصدر
إعلانك  تحافظ Fortas على جنرال موتورز المصنوعة
بالأمس عندما نعلن نعم
لقدرات إضافية لأمريكا الشمالية ،
سيكون هذا هو الوقت المناسب للأسف بالنسبة
لنا ، لدينا الرفاهية لنكون قادرين على الانتظار
حتى تتولى الإدارة
المسؤولية وهي في غضون يومين
ستصبح الأمور على ما
يرام في ديكسي وبعد ذلك ، لكنك ستنقل السعة إلى الولايات المتحدة مرة أخرى.
أود أن أقول إن
القدرات في الولايات المتحدة  أي
صانعي سيارات من الآن فصاعدًا سيزدادون